je me trouve actuellement à saint thomas
en bray dans l'oise pas très loin de
beauvais je viens rencontrer vincent
verschueren est éleveur de vaches
laitières mais une prochaine décision de
justice pourrait mettre un terme à son
activité et lui faire tout perdre il va
nous expliquer cela suivez moi
bonjour se faire suivant merci de nous
recevoir bon on est ici sur votre
exploitation alors si j'ai compris c'est
le bâtiment qui a là bas qui pose
problème c'est ça tu as fait bâtiment là
bas au fond qui est juste à côté des
anciens bâtiments qui pose problème
c'est là dedans que vous avez tout au
tout vos bêtes ça donc les vaches
laitières sont ce bâtiment une partie
des bêtes d'élevage je lui reste des
bêtes sont dans les autres bâtiments qui
était déjà existants on va voir ça on y
va par l'espace
donc là qu'est ce que vous avez comme
type de bêtes ici donc tout le côté
droit du bâtiment c des vaches laitières
qui sont présentes et tout l'autre côté
ces animaux d'élevage donc
principalement les mâles qui sont élevés
dans ce bâtiment par c'est quoi le
problème avec ce bâtiment par la
décision de justice comme vous menace de
tout perdre si j'ai bien compris quel
est le problème exactement le ski a
reproché c'est la proximité des
habitations et qui générerait des
troubles au voisinage risques ça reste
la démolition puisque elle n'a pas été
accordée en première instance mais on
appelle
le peule être prononcées et les dommages
et intérêts qui sont colossaux et pour
une exploitation comme le nôtre se
serait certainement la fin de
l'exploitation
quel est votre quotidien comment est-ce
que vous travailliez ici sur cette
exploitation bachy quotidiennement donc
on avec des vaches laitières donc
forcément la journée commence toujours
par la traite et finit toujours par la
traite ce soir c'est sept jours sur sept
tous les joueurs de l'année le livre de
la poule devant de combien on est sur
une moyenne de 36 centimes
du litre de lait 36 centimes du litre de
lait qui a revendu ensuite dans les
supermarchés qui vendu combien c'est
quoi c'est dû et qu'on voit facilement
retrouver un héros l'it dans les
supermarchés on a souvent entendu les
éleveurs se plaindre du prix du lait
qu'ils n'étaient pas assez élevés sont
le seul on veut avec une marge qui était
trop importante du côté des des grandes
surfaces vous vous vivez avec combien de
cette vente
avec la vente de votre lait un bol
actuellement dire entre 1000 et 1200
euros qu'est ce que devrait payer le
consommateur pour que le prix soit juste
pourquoi salers wade s'en va pour nous
des fois ça joue à peu de chose vous on
monte tout de suite de 2 3 4 centimes le
litre de lait ça paraît peut-être
dérisoire mais ramenés sur le volume bas
l'année ça peut faire une différence
considérable
qui fait qu'on gagne ou qu'on perd de
l'argent ça joue souvent à quelques
centimes il élit si je schématise si
vous vendez votre lait à 40 centimes
voulu le vendre 36 centimes par exemple
ou vous savez quelles différences
au final sur votre salaire à toute façon
si on prend 4 centimes sur le litre ça
fait 40 euros sur 100 millilitres ça
fait 4 ça fait quatre mille euros donc
ça fait tout de suite sur l'exploitation
nous avons besoin de vingt mille euros
de différence bah forcément que ça joue
sur le salaire ça veut dire que pour le
consommateur à consommateur qui serait
certainement prêt à mettre 4 centimes de
plus pour son lait vous permettrait à
vous de gagner 1000 1500 euros de plus
par mois oui bien sûr le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui s'il paye 4 centimes de
plus c'est pas forcément à nous que ça
va revenir c'est d'un tout souci mais
tous bien content d'aller faire une
course tout seul même magasin mais je
pense que voilà on a perdu un certain
contact avec la population peut-être que
il ya ça manquait de communication et si
la profession pendant un certain nombre
d'années
on est en pleine période électorale pour
vous ce mandat d'emmanuel m'a conquis
starlines ça s'est concrétisé comment
pendant ces cinq années
c'est compliqué
puisque bon mais en cinq ans
concrètement on peut faire bouger les
choses toute façon comme on le voudrait
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui au delà qu'on
mette un un parti de différents partis
politiques ça je suis un petit peu entre
guillemets
l'évolution est ce que les citoyens
veulent le nombre de candidats la seule
se précise vous avez déjà entendu des
propositions en provenance de certains
candidats qui vous séduisent
pas encore particulièrement on entendu
qu'ils sont vraiment axé sur une
activité avec l'agriculture biologique
après je pense qu'il faut tous les
modèles il ya pas le modèle parfait vous
le voyez comment le futur de votre
profession
flou très flou